Hello, my name is Zachary Romero and today I'll be going over PSearch, a local search engine in EMAX.
So search these days everywhere in software from text editors to IDs to most online websites
and these tools tend to fall into one of two categories. One are tools that run locally
and work by matching string to text. And the most common example, this is GRIP.
In EMAX there are a lot of extensions which provide functionality on top of these tools,
such as projectile GRIP, deadgrab, consult GRIP, and most editors have some sort of search current
project feature. And most of the time some features, some of these tools have features like
regular expressions or you can specify file extension or director you want to search in,
but features are pretty limited. And the other kind of search we use are usually hosted online.
And they usually search a vast corpus of data. And these are usually
prepared online services such as Google, GitHub, Source Graph for code.
And let's say so, the kind of search feature that editors usually have have a lot of
downsides to them. For one, a lot of times you don't know the exact searching you're searching for.
So some complicated term like this high volume demand partner, you know, do you know if it is it,
are some words abbreviated as a capitalized, is it in Kabab case, Camel case, Snake case, and
you often have to search all these variations. Another downside is that the search results returned
are contained contain a lot of noise. So for example, you may get a lot of test files,
if it if the tool hits your vendor directory, it may get a bunch of results from libraries you're
using, which is which most are not not helpful. Another downside is that the order given is well,
there's no there's no meaning to the order. It's usually just the search order that the tool
happens to look in first. Another thing is so when you're searching, you often have you often
time to have to keep the state of the searches in your head. So for example, you try one search,
you see the results, find the results you you think are relevant, keep them in your head,
run search number two, look through the results, kind of combine these result, these different
search results in your head until you get an idea of which which ones might be relevant.
Another thing is that the search primitives are fairly limited. So yeah, you can search regular
expression, but you can't really define complex things like I want to search files in this directory,
in this and this directory, and this directory, except these subdirectories and accept test files,
and I only want files with this file extension. Criteria like that are really hard to, I'm sure they're
possible in tools like grip, but they're pretty, they're pretty hard to to construct. And lastly,
there's no, there's no notion of any relevance. So all the results you get back, I mean, you don't
know, is this search more relevant? Is it twice as relevant? Is it, is it, is this, is it 100 times more
relevant? These tools usually don't provide such information. So there's a field called information
retrieval, and this deals with this exact problem. So you have lots of data you're searching for,
how do you construct a search query? How do you get results back fast? How do you rank which ones
are most relevant? And how do you, how do you evaluate your search system to see if it's getting
better or worse? So, so there's a lot of work, a lot of books written on the, on the topic of
information retrieval, and if, if one wants to improve searching any max, then drawing inspiration
from this field is, is necessary. So the first aspect of information retrieval is the index. So the,
the reverse index is what search engines use to find results really fast. And essentially, it's a,
it's a map of search term to locations where that, where that term is located. So you'll have,
all the terms, or maybe even parts of the terms, and then you'll have all the locations where they're
located. And so like any query could easily look up where things are located, join, join results
together. And, and that's how they get the results to be really fast. So for, for this project, I
decided to, for go creating an index altogether. As an index is, it's pretty complicated to maintain,
because it always has to be in sync. So anytime you open a file and save it, it would have to re-index
it, have to make sure that file is re-indexed properly. And then you have the whole issue of like, well,
if you're searching any max, like, okay, you have all these projects, this directory, that directory,
how do you know, which you always have to keep them in sync. And so it's, it's quite a hard task
to keep, to handle that. And then on the other end, tools like RIPGrep are, can search very fast,
even though they can't search, maybe, you know, they can't search, maybe on the order of tens of
thousands of repositories. For a local setting, they should be plenty fast enough. I, I benchmarked it,
and it's about like, RIPGrep, for example, is about, it's on the order of gigabytes per second.
So definitely a search of a few pretty big size repositories. So next main task, so,
we decided not to use an index. Next task is how do we rank, how do we rank search results. So there's
two main algorithms that are used these days. So the first one is TFIDF, which stands for term frequency
inverse starting frequency. And then there's BM25, which is sort of a modified TFIDF algorithm.
So TFIDF, without going into too much detail, it's essentially, it essentially multiplies two terms.
One is the term frequency, and then you multiply it by the inverse document frequency. So the term
frequency is a measure of how often that search term occurs. And the inverse document frequency
is a measure of how much information that term provides. So if the term occurs a lot, then it gets
a higher score in the term frequency section. But if it's a common word that exists in a lot of
documents, then it's inverse document frequency goes down. So it's kind of scores at less. So you'll
find that words like the in is these really common words, since they occur in they occur everywhere.
Their inverse document frequency is essentially zero. So they don't really count towards a score.
But when you have like rare words that only occur in a few documents, they're weighted a lot more.
And so the more those rare words occur, they boost the score higher. So BM25 is a modification
of this. It's essentially TF, it's essentially the previous one, except it dampens out terms that
occur more often. So imagine you have a bunch of documents. One has a term 10 times, one has a
term, that same term 100 times, another has a thousand times. You'll find that you'll see the score
dampens up as the as a number of occurrences increases. So that prevents any one term from
overpowering the score. So this is the this is the algorithm I ended up choosing for my implementation.
And so with a so with a plan of using a command line tool like ripgrap to get term occurrences.
And then using the beat like a scoring algorithm like BM25 to rank the rank the current rank the
the terms we can combine this together and create a simple search engine, a simple search mechanism.
So here we're in the directory for the EMAX source code. And let's say we want to search for
say the display code. So we we start we run the p search command opening up starting the
search engine. And it opens up and we notice it has three sections the candidate generators the
priors and the search results. So this candidate generators generates the the search space we're
looking we're we're looking on. So these are all composable and you can add as many as you want.
And so with this it specifies that here we're searching on the file system. And we're searching in
this directory. We're using the ripgrap tool to search with and we want to make sure that we're
searching only on files committed to to get. And here we see the search results. Notice here is
their their final probability. And so here notice that they're all the same and they're the same
because we don't have any search criteria specified here. So suppose we want to search for display
related code. So we add a query display. And so then it spins off the processes gets the search
term counts and calculates the new scores. And notice here that the results that come on top are
are just our first glance a pew to be relevant to display. And so remember if we compare that to
just running a ripgrap raw. Notice here we're getting five fifty three thousand results and
it's it's pretty hard to to go through these results and it makes sense of it.
So that's piece search in a nutshell. Next I wanted to talk about the story of flight
447. So flight 447 going from Rio de Janeiro to Paris crashed somewhere in the Atlantic Ocean on
June 1st 2009 killing everyone on board. Four search attempts were made to find the wreckage. None
of them were successful except the finding of some debris and a dead body. It was decided that they
wanted to they really wanted to find the wreckage to retrieve data as to why the search occurred.
And this was this occurred two years after the initial crash.
So with this next search attempt they wanted to create a probability distribution of where
the crash could be. So the only piece of concrete data they had was a GPS signal from the ship
on at 210. And containing the GPS location that the plane was at 2.98 degrees north 30.59 degrees
west and that was the only data they had to go off of. So they drew a circle around that that point
40 nautical miles right with the radius of 40 nautical miles and they assumed that anything
outside the circle would have been impossible for the ship to reach. So this was the this was a
starting point for for creating the probability distribution of where the wreckage occurred.
So anything outside the circle they assumed it was impossible to reach. The only the only other
piece of data were the four failed search attempts and then some of the debris found.
So one thing they did decide was to look at similar crashes where control was lost to analyze where
those crashes where the crashes landed compared to where the loss of control started and this
probability distribution the circular normal distribution was decided upon. So here you can see that
the center has a lot more a lot higher chance of finding the wreckage and as you as you go away from
the center the probability of finding the wreckage decreases a lot. So the next thing they looked at
was they noticed they had they had retrieved some dead bodies from the wreckage and so they thought
that they could calculate the backward drift on that particular day to find where where the crash
might have occurred. So if they found bodies at a particular location they can kind of work backwards
from that in order to find where the where the initial crash occurred. So here you can see the
probability distribution based off of the the backward drift model. So here you see the darker
darker colors have a higher probability of finding the location. And so with all these pieces of
data. So with the with that circular 40 nautical mile uniform distribution with the with that circular
normal distribution of comparing similar crashes as well as with the back backward drift
distribution they they're able to combine all three of these pieces
in order to come up with a final prior distribution of where the wreckage occurred.
And so this is what this is what the final model they came upon. So here you can see it's it's has
that 40 nautical mile radius circle. It has that that darker center which indicates a higher
probability because of the the crash similarity. And then you hear you also see along this along this
line has a slightly higher probability due to the backward drift distribution. So the next thing is
since they they had performed searches they they were able to they they decided to incorporate
that data the data from those searches into their their new distribution. So here you can see
places where they searched initially. And so if you think about it you can assume that well if you
search for something there's a good chance you'll find it but not necessarily. And so anywhere where
they searched the probability of it finding it there is greatly reduced. It's not zero because obviously
you can look for something and and miss it. But it kind of reduces the probability that we would
expect to find it in those those already searched locations. And so this is this is the posterior
distribution or distribution after counting into after counting observations made. And here we can
see kind of these cutouts of where the previous searches occurred. So this is this is the the final
distribution they went off of to perform the subsequent search. In the end the wreckage was was found
at a point close to the center here thus validating this methodology. We can see the power of this
Bayesian search methodology in this in the way that we could take information from all the sources
we had. We could draw analogies to similar situations. We can quantify these combine them into a
model and then also update our model according to each observation we make. And I think there's a lot
of similarities to be drawn with searching on a computer. In the sense that when we search for
something there's often a oftentimes a story we we kind of have as to like what what search terms
exist where we expect to find the file. So for example if you're implementing a new feature you'll
often have some search terms in mind that you think will be relevant. Some search terms you might
you might think they have a possibility of being relevant but maybe you're not sure. There's some
there's some directories where you know that they're not relevant. There's some there's other criteria
like well you know that maybe somebody in particular worked on this code. And so what if you could
you can incorporate that information like I know this author he's always working on this this
this feature. So what if what if I just give the code the files that this person works on more
more you know a higher probability than once he doesn't work on. Or maybe you think that this
this was a this is a piece of this is a file that's committed to often. You think that maybe the
the amount of times that of commits that receives kind of should change your the probability of
this file being relevant. And so that's where search piece search comes in. So it's it's aim is to
be framework in order to incorporate all these sorts of different prior information
into your searching process. So you're able to say things like I want to I want files authored by
this user to be given higher probability. I want this author to be given a lower priority. I know
this author never works on this code. So if if if he has a commit then lower its probability or you can
specify specific paths or you can specify multiple search terms weighing weighing one different
ones according to according to how you think those terms should be relevant.
So with piece search we're able to incorporate information from multiple sources. So here for
example we have a prior of type git author. And we're we're looking for all of the files that are
committed to by Lars. And so the more commits he has the higher probability is given to that file.
So suppose there's a feature I know he worked on, but I don't know the file or necessarily even
key terms of it. Well with this I can I can incorporate that information. And so let's search again. Let's
add let's add display. And let's see what responses we get back here. And we can add as many of these
these criteria as we want. We can even specify that the title of the file name should should be a
certain type. So let's say we only concerned about c files. So we add the the file name should be
should contain dot c in it. So with this now we notice that all of the c files containing
display authored by Lars should be given higher probability. And we can continue to add these
priors as we feel fit. So the workflow that I found helps when searching is that you'll you'll add
criteria. You'll see some good results come up and some bad results come up. And so you'll
often find a pattern in those bad results like oh I don't want test files or this this director
isn't relevant or or something like that. And then you can update your your prior distribution.
Adding its criteria and then rerun it and then it will get different probabilities for the files.
And so in the end you'll you'll have a list of results that's tailor made to the thing you're
searching for. And so there's a couple of other features I want to go through. So one thing is that
each of these priors they have a you can specify the importance. In other words how
how important is is this is this particular piece of information to your to your search.
So here everything is is of importance medium. But let's say I really care about something having
that we're displaying it. So I'm going to change its importance to instead of medium I'll change
it's I'll change its importance to high. And so it so what it what that does essentially is
things that don't have displaying it are given a much bigger penalty and things with with the word
displaying it is are rated much higher. And so with this we're able to kind of fine tune our
different are the results that we get. Another thing you can do is that you can you can add the complement
or the inverse of certain queries. So let's say you want to search or display but you don't want it
to contain the word frame. So with the complement option on when we create this this search prior
now it's going to be searching for frame but instead of increasing the search score it's going to
it's going to decrease it if it contains the word frame.
Yeah so here things related to frame are kind of deprioritized and we can also say that we really
don't want the search to contain the word frame by increasing its importance. And so with these
with all these composable pieces we can we can create kind of a search that's tailor made to our needs.
So that concludes this talk. There's a lot more I could talk about with regards to
these search so definitely follow the project if you're interested. Thanks for watching and I hope you
enjoy the rest of the conference.